from the new york post editorial board
elon musk's right the left has gone
insane
i don't think we need the new york post
to tell us that elon musk is right about
that but he is
now they show this meme from elon musk
which we talked about the other day it's
from colin wright
and you can see in two you've got this
little these little stick figures people
in 2008 who are left of center and
stayed where they are became centrists
and by 2021 in that same position are
now considered right wing
this is factually true and correct and
the media is desperate to debunk it so
let's let's have this conversation first
let me just show you some some snippets
the washington post immediately said
what elon musk's polarization graph gets
wrong what do they do they show
congressional charts about house
caucuses so you're telling me that
because the democrats march in lockstep
on their policy that means they're not
going far left please let's go down to
how they
so there's a couple things actually
point out but i'll come back in a second
here's how they actually map it out
republicans are far right and the middle
of the road people are center-right the
democrats have moved somewhat to the
left meaning the center is still a
center but the republicans have stayed
where they are ah you see the
republicans have always been far right
the argument from the washington post is
that well the democrats did move far
left but you see the baseline was always
far right so the republicans actually
are far right my attitude is
we the washington post and other media
outlets are trying to create this
narrative
where they've they've created the
they've pinpointed where democrats
moderates and republicans are then taken
the overton window and shifted it so it
puts the conservative in the far right
quadrant and puts them as interests you
can get rid of the the underlying graph
and we can clearly see that democrats
have shifted far to the left it doesn't
matter what you think of conservatives
let me show you a couple tweets
we have this one from the new york times
they do a clever they play a clever game
with this one the republican party has
barely shifted to the right look at this
the democrats
they're what 300 percent further left
here's the game the median party
shows the democrats are only center-left
and they used to be far right
now the new york times can justify the
republicans are far right and the
democrats are just center-left so when
we say the democrats have gone too far
left we're talking about in 2008 barack
obama saying he does not believe in gay
marriage and by 2021 joe biden says
affirm your children
now you've got schools teaching kids
about and you've got
surgeries on children so it's like if
you want to if you want to talk about
where obama used to be and where the
democrats are now the republicans are
are actually to the left republicans are
now pro-lgbt yeah not all of them the
republican party has absolutely moved to
the left that's not even a question and
our cultural culture overall has moved
very swiftly and very far to the left i
can't hear another
analysis completely lacking in
self-awareness from some lefty about how
being on the left is just the normal
default position and therefore moderate
and everyone to the right of them is far
right it's completely ridiculous i think
everyone anyone who isn't on the far
left recognizes that too and so they're
just speaking to their own echo chambers
because i've never heard a conservative
or moderate person say anything along
those lines basically everyone agrees
the left has gone further to the left
and everything else has two so one of
the things they're saying is uh someone
posted this tweet and they were like
mitt romney who was the presidential
nominee for republicans in 2012 is now
considered on the left of the republican
party and we nominated joe biden the
republicans have gone far right blah
blah it's like mitt romney is not called
a leftist
or or a left-leaning person he's called
a rhino and an establishment shill
there's a difference
and joe biden who you nominated
said recently to affirm your children
yeah his his the president for which joe
biden was vice president under
campaigned against gay marriage well
look with mitt romney it's an easy
mistake to make so let me just spell it
out for the audience just because
someone is unbelievably lame doesn't
necessarily mean they're on the left so
it's possible for mitt romney to not be
yeah i think it's a stark um admission
from the left well well here's the other
thing that i love right is that as soon
as when they are our republican nominee
or with the where the republican nominee
the left says they're racist and they're
bigots and they're horrible human beings
like i'm old enough to remember mitt
romney being the worst yeah you know
racist on the planet
and i'm i remember the same thing about
john mcqueen john mccain was every
democrat's favorite republican until he
got the republican nomination and then
keith olbermann's on the tv going he
needs to suspend his campaign right now
and get the white supremacist under
control within his own party so the
bottom line is is that i don't care who
we run right on the republicans i don't
care who they run they're always going
to be a racist sex of sexist bigot
according to the left and then whoever
we run next are like oh gosh i remember
the good old days when it was mitt
romney right
you see what was it uh who who was have
who was it michelle obama somebody was
eating candy with george w bush yeah
oh no ellen well michelle obama and
george bush are also friends she tweeted
out about how he's her partner in crime
something along those lines
i mean like literally i don't know how
that's working i gotta double check i
gotta double check here
i remember in the 2000s going to these
protests
and they would hold up signs of george w
bush with hitler mustache yeah now
this is this hilarious couple years ago
there was a poll that found democrats
had a more favorable view of george w
bush than trump
and that their view of george w bush
moved positive from negative
i'm sorry man y'all have lost the plot
because they don't have principles they
never believe in anything they just they
just repeat whatever their television
tells them to
this is correct it's not like they
didn't like george bush because that
actual reason's not to like george bush
there are very good reasons
very good reasons but that none of those
are why they didn't like them they
didn't like it because they were told
not to and now they're being told to
like them so they go remember the good
old days when bush wasn't i remember the
good old days of uh the protests against
george w bush and then barack obama was
like uh listen here uh i'm gonna be
president and we're gonna end these wars
and then it's like i vote for you sir
thank you for your vote now kill those
kids fire the bombs and i was like wait
wait what are you doing he's like i'm
gonna blow up some kids and i was like
president obama please don't he's like
i'm doing it and then you press the
button and blip kids and i was like you
know what man
but it's different he did it with more
drone strikes right right right actually
he automated the process his only
scandal was a tan suit you guys yeah
that's what i've been told well it's not
a scandal that he killed american
citizens without charge or trial
you know that was just yeah no no no no
no no that wasn't a scandal no i don't
know
if they literally didn't care about his
signing of the mba was scandalous and i
didn't hear enough specifically back on
that specifically the indefinite
detention provision they signed the ndaa
i think every year she should have
ripped that thing apart along with the
patriot act that's the energy he came
into office with but dude like do you
genuinely think barack obama was opposed
to those i think he was and then
realized he'd get killed by the deep
state if he did anything about it after
like the third day
yeah remember okay this let's move
campaign by michelle obama they got an
office it's like all right we're cutting
sugar out of our diets let's move let's
get healthy like a week couple weeks go
by and this is in katie kirk's
documentary fed up which is great uh and
then all of a sudden the let's move
campaign got co-opted by the sugar
industry and became about an exercise
campaign let's work out it doesn't
matter what you eat just keep eating
your sugar let's just let's move totally
twisted they got twisted by the people
they surrounded themselves by the people
that he surround themselves by were
oligarchs shockingly i mean he came into
office and said abe lincoln was his hero
when he left office teddy roosevelt was
his hero because he realized he couldn't
do what abel did that's with the energy
he had i i agree to a certain extent but
it's also possible that he was lying
when he was running for office wow that
was a big lie yeah it was all lies one
of the first things he did was signed
off on the bombing of a pakistani
village killing women and children i'm
more to think that he got twisted by it
i mean how can you get into that
position and not in one twisted yeah so
before he even got in he was probably
getting groomed he got
choice of words good one uh he gets he
gets inaugurated and then he he goes
into office and he's like i want to do
all these uh really great things and
they're like here are the documents and
he opens them up oh i've been
radicalized blow up those kids
it was we got a couple of daughters
it was a few days into his first term
that he authorized these strikes in
villages
he was lying they were all lying they
all campaigned on stuff
the one person who didn't lie in my
lifetime was donald trump that ron paul
is pretty good about oh yeah no rod
rogers
doctor dr paul is the man and hold on
hold on i want to clarify the same about
trump trump lies about stupid things
related to like his personal life and
like yeah his his his his gravitas but
when divines are big and glorious right
when donald trump said i want to end
these wars he really really tried no new
wars he was trying as hard as he could
to get he said i'm going to keep this
promise he wanted to build the wall he
started building a wall i'm like okay
well that guy's doing what he said he
wanted to do barack obama was like we're
going to end these wars and then within
a few days he was like i'm blowing up
kids yeah well there's a reason the deep
state tried to unseat donald trump and
they didn't have the same effort
directed towards barack obama he did
everything they wanted him to the crate
the crazy thing about trump cause when
trump first got into the race i'm
thinking to myself you've got to be
kidding me like you have got to be
kidding me there's no way i trust this
guy and what what shocked me was when he
went in there is one of the biggest
areas where i i thought oh my gosh i
can't believe how great he is was on
foreign policy precisely because i i
always found myself in this weird place
where you got one people over here
that's like let's invade everything
right and then you got another group
over here like you should never go to
war for any reason whatsoever i'm like
actually i think there's actually kind
of a good middle ground here and trump
really did take that position where it
was
he would kick your ass
right but he wasn't just going to do it
arbitrarily i mean when he had a perfect
excuse if he wanted to escalate with
what happened with iran and the the
bombing at the iraq embassy
um he had a perfect opportunity to be
able to really double down on that the
fact that he came back he goes i'm not
going to drone strike somebody and kill
a bunch of innocent people in the hopes
that i'll get a couple bad guys right
because one it's a moral two it's
actually counterproductive on a
practical level and i'm sitting here
going i did if you would have told me
this would have been donald trump
talking this much you know common sense
on foreign policy five years ago i would
have said you were nuts but he was
well we had a great economy um covet
happened last year of his presidency he
takes some of the blame for some of what
went down because he was advocating for
some of this lockdown stuff too and then
everything got out of control you give
the government an inch to take a mile uh
i think he did a pretty good job and i
think he deserves another term
especially coming up 2024.
i think what we're seeing with the
recession or retraction of the economy
by 1.4 i'd call that the death knell for
the democratic party thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you